[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a comedy family film
called the home in the tree
spoilers ahead watch out and take
[Music]
care in a village of the central shaoxi
plane lives a kid named ba wang he is
often misjudged by the teachers because
of his bad grades one morning while the
students of grade five are studying
outside their class ba wang is busy
trying to steal comic books from the
library he builds a makeshift hook to
fish the books but is caught by
principal yin the man is ba wang's
biggest hater he doesn't support his
creativity and thinks he's good for
nothing on being scolded for taking the
books ba wang retaliates it turns out
that he had lent the said books to the
school library to share with other kids
but the principal misused them to show
it to the education department as the
school's property they were never
returned to bow wang so he frequently
tries to retrieve them his chinese
teacher miss jiao is in the seventh
month of pregnancy when she asks ba wang
to make a sentence out of a word he
unknowingly calls her fat and is sent
out of the classroom similarly in the
following period he is made to stand at
the end of the classroom for not solving
a math problem being punished has turned
into a daily routine for bo wang that
day after school ba wang goes to a field
nearby it has a tree that he is marked
as his own every day after school he
climbs up it and stays there for hours
it is his favorite place in the world
miss zhao had asked him to meet her at
the teacher's quarter after memorizing
the homework that he forgot to do that
day ba wang does is told but finds a
beautiful woman instead of miss zhao in
her room the woman is miss fenn a
substitute teacher who is going to take
miss jiao's place during her maternity
leave unlike most teachers fenn is kind
and patient with the kids according to
her there are no bad students only bad
teachers when ba wang tells her that he
hasn't had lunch she asks him to come
back later but right after miss zhao
arrives and refuses to let him eat until
he memorizes the homework miss fenn
calls her out for being mean to the kid
but she rationalizes it by claiming that
botwang deserves it for being naughty
fenn notices ba wang trying to drink
water from a dry faucet and hands him a
jar of pickle juice as a treat baahuang
is foreign to such treatment from a
mentor hence he starts to like her
instantly after the meeting he goes to
take a swim in the nearby lake the
school principal recognizes the clothes
on the ground and brings them back to
school poor ba wang has to use grass to
cover himself on the way back home the
next day he is given the clothes back
and is made to write a self-criticism
letter as a punishment for swimming in
an unsanitary place in the following
scene bowang and his friends are playing
games with a street vendor they are told
if they fish out 10 blue marbles from a
pouch they will be given a gift of their
choice ba wang uses his own marbles to
cheat the vendor but it turns out that
the man had been fooling them all along
since there are no blue marbles in the
pouch they get into a fight and are
stopped by miss fenn she takes the kid
to his parents and vouches for him in
front of them but even after that his
father beats him bowing's mother loves
her son as he is but his father is
always nitpicking on his flaws the next
day is miss fen's first day at work she
allows the kids to read comics hoping
that it will improve their grammar the
students are ecstatic because they have
never been allowed to do so by the
former teacher ba wang is even happier
when she makes him the librarian and
puts him in charge of lending and
collecting the books he does the task
efficiently and feels great to have that
kind of authority over his classmates it
is his first accomplishment in five
years of going to school he brags about
it to his father who as always remains
unimpressed instead of praising him he
urges the kid to get better grades
instead of wasting his time the
following morning bow wang goes to pick
up the books from miss fen she has a
problem with her bed that he solves by
getting pieces of wood from her
carpenter father fenn gives him a candy
as a reward which makes the kid like her
even more in only a week of teaching
miss fenn becomes everyone's favorite
teacher instead of just lecturing the
students she engages them in the class
and lets them discover their creative
side the principal and other teachers
are not very fond of her techniques as
they believe that she is letting the
kids misbehave one day bowing leaves
miss fenn a bunch of mushrooms as a gift
later she looks for him and finds him
under his favorite tree they watch birds
play on the swing and have a great time
together meanwhile ba wang continues
lending the books and becomes quite
popular among his classmates he even
lends the nicer books to the ones with
better grades and encourages the others
to study harder so miss fenn would be
praised for her work during school nap
time bowing falls off the bench and
hurts himself a sympathetic fan allows
him to sleep on her bed in the teacher's
quarter however the plan backfires when
ba wang takes a longer nap than he is
supposed to and is found by the
principal in her bed he punishes the kid
and gives him the last warning before
telling his father about him breaking
into a teacher's room ba wang doesn't
tell the principal the truth fearing
that miss fenn might get in trouble that
night the principal calls out miss fenn
for allowing the kids to read comics
when they're supposed to study for their
upcoming exam she apologizes and
promises to seize the comics until the
exams are over when ba wang comes to
receive the books the next morning he is
told to focus on his studies instead
miss fenn encourages him by promising to
let him read all the books he wants if
he passes with a better score bahwang
takes on the challenge and starts to
study harder than ever initially he
struggles being one of the lowest
ranking ones in the class but with hard
work and determination he soon gets the
hang of it the day before the exam he
gets nervous and decides to write cheats
all over his body miss fenn finds him
while he's at it and makes him take a
bath in the lake to take it off during
the exam bawang is pleasantly surprised
to see the questions are not as
difficult he does his best without
taking help from anyone else a week
later the results are published and he
scores 73 out of 100 as opposed to
failing as usual ms fen is proud of him
to say the least she feels accomplished
that she was the reason he felt
motivated to study harder she even
complements his hard work in front of
the class bahwang can not stop talking
about his day at dinner his mother is
beyond happy to see her son finally
studying harder but his father is
pessimistic as always why do the dads in
these stories always have a stick up
their ass he urges bow wang to get an
honorary award that the top three
students get only then will he gain his
respect the mother tries to change the
topic but he continues to undermine his
son's accomplishments the following day
at school miss fenn suggests the
principal at an award for the student
who made the most progress in the last
semester but since the school cannot
afford to award more students he
declines during the awards ceremony
bahwang is on his toes hoping that his
name will be called he wants to prove
his worth to his father but is left
disappointed by the end of the ceremony
miss fenn feels bad for the kid and
makes him a certificate of his own using
blank paper and lipstick balwang is
handed this in front of the class she
also takes his picture for memories miss
fenn is getting more suss by the second
after school he runs to his home and
shows the certificate to his parents his
mother puts it on the wall proud of him
but his father grouches about it not
being an official certificate still for
one day bahuang couldn't care less about
what his father thinks he is overjoyed
that a teacher like miss fenn existed in
his life starting the next day balwing's
classmates follow him around wanting to
be with the cool guy of the class they
also beg him to ask miss fenn to take
their pictures too bawwang brags that he
can manage it since he is very close
with miss fenn she even calls him her
groomer one morning he goes to her room
to receive the comic books for the day
but the principal sends him away because
miss fenn is on a holiday during nap
time ba wang can not fall asleep because
of her absence he cleverly sneaks out of
the class and breaks into miss fen's
room after looking around for a while he
finds the camera and brings it outside
all of a sudden he notices miss fenn and
a guy entering the school he immediately
runs to her room and puts the camera
back in its place before hiding under
the bed miss fenn and her friend enter
the room and start calling each other
affectionate pet names bon wang suspects
that they are a couple and his suspicion
is proven correct when they kiss
fortunately he is not caught in the
incident but the revelation does make
his day worse the next morning bawang
walks into miss fen's room to find her
boyfriend naked on her bed the man helps
ba wang with the comic books and then
goes back inside the room although he is
only a kid bonwang is filled with
jealousy seeing that his favorite person
is affectionate towards someone else he
may be bawwing but that guy has a man
wang before returning home he hears fenn
compliment her boyfriend's looks the
next day he takes an hour-long bath gels
his hair with glue and wears clean
clothes in hopes of impressing fan at
school his friends make fun of him
comparing his hair to a hedgehog miss
fenn doesn't notice the change and asks
him to take her and her boyfriend to the
tree that he loves so much she thinks
that the place is romantic where she can
spend quality time with her boyfriend
bahwang has to reluctantly take them to
the field and show them around the
boyfriend plays on the swing while ba
wang and fen hang out on the tree a
while later the couple goes cycling
together taking advantage of their
absence ba wang uses a knife to cut the
rope of the swing he hopes to make the
guy fall off of it but the plan fails
when miss fenn swings on it next and
gets hurt as she screams in pain the
screen goes blank and the scene changes
to two weeks later barwang is studying
in class still influenced by fenn even
though she has stopped teaching the
school during the lunch break he
receives a letter from her in the letter
she claims that she misses him and
everyone else in the class she also
encourages him to continue working hard
so he can one day get the official
certificate from the principal it turns
out that she is in the hospital because
of a broken arm but is recovering well
she also graduated the past week and has
sent a picture of herself as a memento
in the last scene balwang goes to his
favorite tree which unfortunately has
been cut down he buries the letter and
pictures in the front as he walks away
we see a tiny twig growing from its bark
indicating that the tree will stand tall
again
sometime in the future
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching